this is a production of Cornell
University thank you okay all right
thank you for having me I'm excited to
be here today to talk about native
plants this cover photo kind of shows
the three prongs of my work which is
looking at landscape adaptability
propagation and production in containers
or I don't want to say new native plants
because they're not new to the planet
but new to the horticultural industry so
so to say novel novel native native
shrubs mostly and the reason why I
started or I guess my work with natives
started with my dissertation work on
invasives so for my my doctoral work I
looked at the contributions of cultivars
of Japanese Barbary and winged euonymus
to invasive populations because at the
time the state of Connecticut was facing
bans they were enacting a voluntary ban
on Japanese Barbary cultivars with high
fruiting and they were looking for safe
alternatives particularly native plant
alternatives and kind of did wanted to
get away from Barbary I was tired of the
thorns and the scratched arms and
fingers and the thorns will last for
months under your skin and I may still
have some coming up and there's a long
time ago and but the question was you
know can can natives fill the gap left
by Japanese Barbary cultivars that are
incredibly tough and can grow in
parking-lot islands and highlight high
heat high pedestrian pressure salt
runoff they can propagate and grow in
containers very easily so can you have
native shrubs that can do the same thing
one of the first plants that I looked at
was nine bark because it was a direct
replacement for Barbary purple foliage
cultivars yellow foliage cultivars
probably today they're on one of the
fewer only
recked replacements for purple Barbary
is still this plant I could think of
there's some purple red and orange
leaves dear villas now but they're
really more southern natives and we
looked at powdery mildew susceptibility
and the cultivars that were available at
the time and we had yellow foliage
cultivars and purple foliage cultivars
and we found that the older cultivar
næss with smaller leaves was largely
resistant to powdery mildew and this
paper actually is probably one of my
most cited papers we very useful to not
only plant breeders and scientists but
also no nursery growers and landscapers
and from this work a lot of breeding was
done to develop new cultivars this is
some of the new cultivars since that
study and a lot of them have made this
as a parent so using that resistance to
breed in or better landscape plants I
think this is the cultivar Donna Mae at
the coastal Maine Botanical Gardens
which features a lot of native plants if
you're into native plants it's worth a
visit up there so wrapping up the nine
bark work I started to think about other
native plants and there were a good
number that were widely used very
important landscape plants like winter
berry Holly and the creeping juniper by
Burnham den Tatum red twig dogwood that
were popular important native plants but
overall it seemed like native plants
were being overlooked for landscape
potential and this is a trade show
display showing the proven winners here
on your left and American beauties
native plants brand on the right and you
know if you were a consumer which
display would you choose from and it's
really not the native plants fault it's
just we don't know didn't know how to
grow them in containers they're smaller
pots you know how to force them for
display propagation was difficult mostly
done by seed which doesn't yield uniform
crops so it seemed like there was a lot
of potential to develop new natives or
additional natives that could be
adaptable
so one of the first things that we did
is we put native shrubs that were not
commonly available or widely used in a
tough landscape site on the Yukon campus
and parking lot islands alongside
barbarian euonymus here's here they are
and so this was just one site and we had
this replicated and we did the first
round in 2010 with those six natives up
there we did another round in 2012 to
2014 with another eight native plants
and crimson pygmy Barbary and compact
this euonymus as controls and when we
first put this study in I thought
everything was going to die after the
first winter and there'd barbarian
euonymus would be standing just really
pleasantly surprised that most
everything survived and performed well
and so we measured aesthetic quality and
survival and things like that this was a
really a tough side when you dug it up
it was largely backfill from the
construction of these dorms it was hot
highlight there's a huge commuter
parking lot there called W lot in this
site we used another parking lot for
round two part of another parking lot so
not much to support the plants so this
is the aesthetic quality index results
for that first study and you can see the
crimson pygmy barbarian euonymus here
and this was aesthetic quality in 2010
2011 and 2012 and there were you know
several plants like the sweet fern and
the sweet gal that right out of the gate
performed as well as the invasives and
they several of them that kind of lagged
behind were just as good as the
Barbarian euonymus by the third year and
so that was you know make a good
recommendation that these would can
certainly be alternatives for barbarian
euonymus in tough sites so I want to
talk about some of these plants because
with some of these plants I took the
research a step further and looked at
propagation and production in containers
median fertility and shading in that
kind of thing so I'm gonna talk about a
few of these then I'll show you the
results of the second parking lot and
talk about some of those and that's kind
of how it's gonna flow okay okay
so come Tonio peregrina I don't know if
I saw some of these natives on campus I
don't know if I saw this one but I
believe it's here the sweet fern is a
really interesting plant
it's a pioneer plant it fixes nitrogen
in the soil through these root nodules
and Frankia bacteria that fixes nitrogen
so it comes in after a forest fire or
after a clearing and it rejuvenates the
soil for other plants to then come in so
it's very adaptable to dry gravelly
nutrient deficient soils like you see in
a parking lot island or a commercial
landscape site so these are the plants
in the parking lot this was at the bus
stop location there it is right next to
the wings euonymus so it's a nice dense
plant when full Sun and some people say
that it's not that long-lived but this
is going into its sixth season it gets
to that you know three to four foot
height nice and compact dense it has a
wonderful fragrance to the foliage
especially on a warm sunny day so you
can smell like Cinnabon in the parking
lot but you wouldn't expect but a really
interesting plant here it is kind of
being used as a hedgerow at coastal
Maine botanical gardens or a shrub e
ground cover under trees this was a neat
parking lot at a Lowe's in Maine or kind
of as naturalizing I think that the
sweet fern is a real sweetheart plant
for a lot of people but the problem with
it has been propagation it's difficult
to propagate so it doesn't produce a lot
of seeds the seeds need smoke or fire to
break their dormancy and if you can't
take readily take stem cuttings softwood
stem cuttings and the traditional sense
so it's largely propagated by digging up
sods divide
the rhizomes so one of the first studies
that I did as an assistant professor
leaving barbary behind was look at media
or doing rhizome divisions and we used
vermiculite and Safford mix and sand and
it was it was very easy to propagate
from divisions you could take small
two-inch segments and and get plants
these are actually the plants that I
raised up and put in the parking lot
I'll endure a couple of years later and
I'm still working with this plant I had
an undergrad last year do some stem
cuttings from very young shoots so when
they get to be no more than three inches
tall coming up from the rhizome and more
recently shown that it'll work from
shoots as well but very young stems
roots readily with an IBA oxen and they
can make nice dense plants and you can
even get reefs well after you take
cuttings from the rhizomes and this is
the data from that work which is not yet
published and just showing that we use
two different propagation systems we
used an intermittent mist just straight
putting it in the mist with a little bit
of a with them covering over it for
shade it was just kind of like an upside
down flat and we used a propagation dome
a clear dome and the mist worked a lot
better I mean 98% rooting for canto Nia
is wonderful the dome didn't do too bad
about 70 percent rooting what happened
with the dome was the tips would dry out
a little bit it wasn't as as humid in
there and that actually promoted lateral
branching so we got slightly larger
plants with the dome but better rooting
with the mist so you could perhaps
recommend rooting and mist and pinching
to get greater branching and then we
grew the mountain containers and three
thousand one thousand to three thousand
IBA maybe a little bit higher you can
get you know 80% or more rooting and
sound of developing native ARS I'll talk
a little bit more about that towards the
end
we have raised this interesting clone of
canto Nia that has a bluish cast to the
foliage a kind of a very uniform margin
to the leaf and nice kind of branching
and symmetry to the plan and the
University of Connecticut is looking to
patent this now to you know to get into
production see about that another plant
that is also has scented foliage is
America pencil nope that's wrong it
should be miracle Gail sorry that's
incorrect
sweet Gail is merica Gail it's still
merica
so the bayberry is now Marella but this
is America Gail and normally you'd find
it in around the edge margins of lakes
streams freshwater mostly it has this
kind of frosty lime green foliage it's
not it's deciduous so it's it's a cousin
of the bay berry it doesn't have the the
berries with the candle wax on them
they're a more of a catkin but here it
is growing in the parking lot Islands
here's crimson pygmy Barbary it's a very
low plan one to two feet it has this
kind of arching candelabra like habit to
it the stems are kind of a brown purpley
brown with yellow white yellow lenticels
on it scented foliage it's tends to be
Manisha sword Ayesha sand there are male
and female plants the clone we had in
the parking lot was a male and the male
catkins can be really showy in early
spring very early spring here this is
some that we put near my house I think
and this is two years later so you can
get a nice hedgerow low in the parking
lots I've seen you know bird's nest in
it this is actually in Rockland Maine
near marina so you can see trying to be
used here at landscape architects have a
good novel idea there it's a really cold
hardy plant
I think it's found all the way up maybe
into Alaska the growers says that it's
very easy to propagate so I didn't do a
lot of studies with this I just tried it
with you know Hormann in one it routes
very well it grows very fast you could
probably go right from a cutting into a
number one in one year you can prune it
share it and it's very dense so it's a
said that's what you know growers like
something that's fast to grow takes a
typical bark piece and media and control
release fertilizer so northern Bush
honeysuckle deer Villalon asura this is
I saw this on campus I saw the southern
incest Allah so Leah and and this one as
well this was in the parking lot Islands
uh not as popular among nursery growers
but it should be because it's very
adaptable it stays really low it's a
terrific B plant so this is me this was
one near my driveway you can just sit
and watch the bumblebees all day has
these um clusters of tubular yellow
flowers at the tips of the shoots
reddish foliage on the new growth this
was in the parking lot so the first year
they didn't look as good because they
came this is in 2010 they came from the
nursery and they hadn't been spaced in a
timely manner at the nursery so as soon
as we spread them out the shoots fell
over so we've got a poor visible rating
but they this basically they just
resprayed from the base and that's one
thing you can do with this plant you can
prune it back readily and have it you
know Reese proud and make a dense plant
and this was you know year three I think
we had the coat of our copper which
tends to get really red new growth
there's copper right there at the
coastal Maine Botanical Gardens this was
an outside of a daycare center in stores
downtown stores Connecticut and this is
on the UConn campus and this is at
coastal Maine and this is that planting
I was looking at the bees act we can get
a nice fall color and I saw a huge
planting that I'm bigger than I've ever
seen on campus here I don't know what
building it was at but it was a big
swath of it I took a picture
this is out a parking lot out in the
Minnesota they're using it a lot out
there the button Bush is another one
that when people saw this in the parking
lots they were shocked that it would
grow because typically it's a plant that
you find on the edge of water with its
roots submerged in the water but
sometimes native plants are adaptable to
a niche outside of where you find them
but in those areas they maybe don't
compete but and they'll do fine in these
tougher areas and so that's where you
see them but it doesn't necessarily mean
that they can't be used in a landscape
in a different way and that's the case
with button Bush because here it is in
the bus stop parking lot island doing
quite well in a quick draining not too
wet but maybe it offers a little bit of
moisture soil this is kind of the
typical use in a rain garden but it can
it can do well in drier sites maybe not
completely dry but it can do quite well
outside of its niche
it's very desirable for it's interesting
inflorescences these golf ball-sized
white flower clusters that attract lots
of pollinators and and these fruits kind
of persist they turn a reddish and then
a black and they'll persist into the
winter they're very easy to propagate
from seed they don't need any cold
stratification or anything like that
but there's a lot of diversity from seed
and not so desirable diversity sometimes
you know different leaves different
habits so if you were a designer this
may not be so desirable for you and
there are some cultivars of this which
is what's really important for this
plant to make it in the nursery trade to
have a little bit more symmetry and
stability or predictability so there's
Sputnik which is an older cultivar sugar
shack which is a really good cultivar a
little bit more compact three to four
feet here are some new ones that are not
as as well tested as sugar chef
this is the American filbert and this is
mark right here and in the parking lot
Islands this is a wild plant this is
just showing the size because he's about
six foot so it's big it gets a nice fall
color there's two native filbert's
there's the American filbert and there's
the beaked filbert which is coral ascore
nuda it's the coral ascore nuta is the
plant that I wanted for the parking-lot
Islands because I thought it had a more
finer texture a little bit more
ornamentally pleasing but this is
they're very difficult to distinguish
and this is what I got from the nursery
American filbert which we realized about
a year later but it did very well it had
this really there's the burning bush
right there next to it this nice kind of
mix of fall foliage color the American
filbert has this ruffled involucre and
we did find from raising some seed of
this a compact form called a little
filly so I'm still working on
propagation of this it's not easy the
filbert's are not so easy but we did do
a study with the beaked filbert that's
coming up the beaked filbert is the
easiest way to distinguish it from the
American filbert is by the involute Urso
it's shaped more like a duck beak versus
kind of the ruffled shirt sleeve this is
it at the Minnesota botanic garden or
Arboretum and this one tends to be a
little bit more in the colder areas with
then the American but they they
certainly overlap and there's other ways
you can tell the American filbert apart
from the beach filbert the fall color
the the beaked gets more of a yellow I
know it's these are wild shoots the
catkins size but they both produce
edible nuts
the Silbert nut so we did a propagation
we looked at several difficult to root
natives the new jersey t here's the
beech filbert northern Bush honeysuckle
and viburnum a seraph Oleum and we found
that you can get pretty good rooting if
you take cuttings in July treat them
with
at least three thousand
parts-per-million IBA you can route the
beach filbert pretty well and then we
took the plants from this study and some
of the others and put them in a
container production study and this was
looking at shale as a media amendment
trying to recreate those dry gravelly
soils you see this in along the sides of
the roads in Connecticut and it didn't
really matter it grew well in all media
so you can use a standard bark pizza to
grow nice-looking big children's so
another plant that was not in the
parking lot study but was in these
propagation studies was maple leaf by
Burnham by Burnham Acer folium this is a
great shade plant dry shady conditions
it's a highly sought after plant for the
foliage it's this maple leaf looking
foliage it gets wonderful fall color
this is a seedling in the woods some of
the natural history descriptions of
these plants are beautiful writing about
you know this plant in this kind of
ghostly fall pinkish white yellow color
and so it's really sought after by
nurseryman as well but it's very hard to
propagate so they buy it in as rooted
cuttings or they buy it in his side bare
root and it was hard to to propagate it
has the typical viburnum flowers
clusters of small white flowers they're
pink and buds so sometimes you get pink
buds and white flowers at the same time
and blue-black fruits and so we did this
plant as well so and we did single node
cuttings and then we also tried two node
cuttings and had a hundred percent
rooting with two node cuttings so that's
the trick with this plant the problem is
when people are take collecting native
plants from the wild you're not going to
readily get a vegetative chute where you
can take two node cuttings you're going
to see a single node a pair of leaves
and then a flower and that roots not as
well more in the like fifty sixty
percent so
and also if you give a plant time in
container production you may find taking
cuttings from container plants will
yield better results and sometimes
you'll get vegetative shoots when you're
growing a plant in a bark peeps and mix
with high fertility it'll go more
vegetative and then you can take
cuttings so we found two nodes and it's
hard to see but there was there are two
nodes on this this is the grow out after
a winter so we told growers that
hopefully they're trying that and we
also looked at pruning to try to yield a
more dense plant in a pot so people like
to get plants that have you know nice
rounded uniform canopy in a container
not kind of you know pigtail in a pot
like a lot of natives look like and soap
root you can prune these plants as well
to get a more uniform height to width
ratio so this is the second study the
parking lots which were established in
2012 and in this year we had heavy deer
pressure so we use that as a measure we
evaluated deer browse or deer of every
based on the rating system so here you
can see natives like the prunus
cumulative oppressor the creeping sand
cherry elderberry
the gray dogwood and round leaf dogwood
we had a spicebush we had blueberry as
kind of a pseudo control and Virginia
rose and sweet bells with the same two
invasive controls the blueberry is a
plant that from from day one has been
popularized as an alternative for the
burning bush but there's a lot of mixed
reports on how well it establishes in a
tough landscape
it likes acidic soils and while it's
drought tolerant once established it
requires I find regular watering to get
it established so you can't just put it
in the ground and you set it and forget
it like a burning bush so it was kind of
in there as let's see how it did and it
didn't do that well one of the lowest
survival
rates after two years it had a little
bit of deer browse actually and you know
not a great aesthetic rating whereas
plants like this unknown plant the sweet
bells u-boat rest's racing also used to
be Lakota we're a samosa did really well
Virginia Rose did well the dogwoods had
a quite a bit of deer browse same thing
with the spicebush not the greatest
survival good amount of deer browse so I
want to talk about this plant sweet
bells and about the creeping sand cherry
and a couple of other plants so this is
the sweet bells it has bell shaped
flowers with a very light fragrance it
looks kind of like a blueberry but a
little bit denser than a blueberry and a
lot tougher than a blueberry easy to
establish here are the plants in a
parking lot island and it gets some
plants some ecotypes get really nice red
fall color it's very easy to propagate
from cuttings you know seventy to eighty
eight percent with no hormone so it's
very easy to propagate which is good for
grows grows fast in a pot you can cheer
it and stick those cuttings at any time
we did a shade production study with
these plants and a couple of other
species and found you know you can grow
them right under full Sun or under forty
percent shade and they will make a nice
kind of height to with uniform ratio
with a good number of shoots these are
one gallon sized pots in this study we
also looked at hobble Bush and in the
propagation study we looked at how much
so this one wasn't in the parking lot
Islands because it's a shade plant kind
of like the Maple Leaf viburnum it likes
cool climates it likes moist soils but
well-drained its kind of picky but it's
a gorgeous plant a highly sought after
plant it gets these red fruits these big
leaves fuzzy leaves a little bit fuzzy
these white lacecap flowers fuzzy buds
so it's really sought asked
among native plant enthusiasts very
difficult to propagate from cuttings and
it's not that easy from seed I've never
tried it but that's what I hear so I
don't know if we just came across the
right plant in Massachusetts that roots
but we rooted it pretty well we had you
know 70% rooting with three thousand one
thousand two eight thousand
parts-per-million IBA this is what they
were short little shoots so one little
note because that's all you can get off
of the landscape so there were these
short little shoots that were barely in
the media and these leaves eventually
just dried up and came right off over
the winter and this is the outgrowth the
following spring they were potted up
before they leapt out or as they were
starting to and here they're they're
growing out and then we put this plan in
that shade study so a typical bark
Pete's and mix and they definitely
benefit from growing in shade we had
leaf burn and full Sun even some leaf
coloring discoloring in 40% shade but
you can get you know a nice looking
container plant with shade seventy
percent shade the creeping sand cherry
this is it in the parking lot island so
you almost can't tell that it's there
and the outside landscaping crew
couldn't tell that it was there so they
mowed over it a couple of times but it's
a great low less than a foot plant with
these kind of linear leaves that emerge
a little bit after the flowers or just
as the flowers are emerging they have a
classic kind of rose AC flower
I've peddled white flower silver
undersides to the leaves that can get
kind of a red burgundy fall color this
is in our lilac garden on the UConn
campus over some some slate so very low
growing this is the the native knoll
that we call it at my house this rocky
area these were one two there were three
maybe five of these from a one gallon
pot
and this was it maybe last year so it's
a great kind of facer plant or along the
edge of a driveway or something where
you get hot baking Sun and then it'll
it'll do just fine this is kind of the
other view of the rock that's my son
several years ago so you can see it's
kind of like a driveway planting just
kind of creeping over for a rock garden
it's very easy to root cuttings these
are actually cuttings from Canterbury
horticultural nursery in Connecticut and
you can get nice dense 1 gallon pots
this is a cultivar that Mark developed
mark sitting right there he's from UConn
he crossed
prunus cumulative Araya t de presa and
prunus Susquehanna so it's a it's a
creeping plant with a little bit larger
leaf the same white flowers and red fall
color grows really well in a container
and a university I think is looking to
as well you know native plants that
behave well in a landscape and still
offer wildlife benefits I think is what
the nursery industry is looking for now
this plant deer berry is one that I've
been working on recently and I have a
paper coming out native plants journal
this fall on micro propagation so deer
berry has a pretty broad native range it
can be really big and it can get more
compact like this specimen here it's in
the blueberry group but it doesn't
produce sweet tasting fruits they're
edible but not really palatable but it
is being used in blueberry breeding to
introduce kind of exotic flavors and
colors and upload adaptation so it's
it's drought taught more drought
tolerant so this is kind of at my house
by rock here and these are some of the
ornamental features this is from the
publication which is why it's all
labeled up like this you know you get
these kind of star like flowers in
abundance you get the fruit is usually
starts out greenish to blue and then it
turns these kind of burgundy orangey
colors it
can get nice read fall color like the
blueberries do it does not root well
from cuttings at all so that's what we
tried first with poor root systems and
then we thought let's try it in tissue
culture and we looked at different iron
supplements in tissue culture because
sometimes the leaves looked a little
chlorotic and we did routing and it
propagates you know with 80% success
from for micro propagation so that's one
way to go about it for breeders or
growers looking for this plant here they
are acclimating and a salad tray
acclimating to the greenhouse and these
are one gallon containers so I'm still
working with native plans I have a grad
student right now looking at pollinator
visitation on native shrubs and their
cultivars so native plants when I first
started working with them they were
desirable as alternatives to invasives
and now when the PHA later concern and
worry hit it was all about you need
native plants for pollinators and then
you started to hear some group saying
that the cultivars of native plants were
not as supportive of pollinators as the
wild type species and you know that
concerns growers and that's not really
based in scientific study so we did a
study we collected some native shrubs
species and their cultivars and put them
in a planting behind our greenhouse and
this is my master student Jacob and he's
counting insect visitation and this work
is is wrapping itself up so hopefully
we'll get get this out soon and and most
of the cultivars are very good at
supporting pollinators there's a few
that have dramatic changes like a flower
color that maybe attract a different
suite of pollinators but not always and
many of the cultivars that just exhibit
a more compact habit attract just as
many pollinators of the same type and
some even have greater floral density
and attract more pollinators another
thing I'm working on is looking at
developing
local native cultivars so looking at
local ecotypes and which ones exhibit
the best ornamental qualities and
adaptability because this is a you boat
restoration mosa from Connecticut and
this is a you boat restoration mosa from
Connecticut and one clearly is more you
know you know I think you know prides
corner would be more interested in
picking up this plant than this one and
there's certainly more interested in
growing them vegetatively so they can
offer a uniform crop and from seed so
which is not just germinate swell but
they're itty bitty bitty seeds with this
plant so it's kind of a pain to deal
with them in a plug tray and that's it
by one o'clock I think that was right so
any questions okay well I mean maybe
that should be tested you know cuz maybe
they will tolerate outside I don't know
you put them in and they haven't done
well they're here according to the
native maps but okay well I think that
with native plants it is going to be a
regional issue so I mean there's some
plants that have a really broad range
but that's one of the issues with the
whole patenting cultivar process and
trying to get our tech transfer people
to realize that you can't necessarily
market these plants across you know the
nursery industry like you can a bar
berry so it with native selections it's
going to be a more regional focus
right yeah well like yeah I think that
on the western half of Connecticut they
have more limestone e soils as well but
some of the plants might do okay like
this I didn't include the spiraea but
the tomentosa is being looked at in the
Midwest and they've done actually I
think some pH studies Minnesota maybe
with that plan yeah so tomentosa so
that's one so maybe some of these others
but yeah it has been a more kind of pH
yeah okay consider that thank you
okay okay so with the pollinators where
they're native and non-native colonies
yes so I mean we looked at the honeybees
and which is not native and yeah I think
he looked at I mean for some things I
think he had about he has about twelve
insect groups so he had like hover flies
and mining bees and bumblebees honey
bees and then he had smaller groupings
you know like other flies and sweat bees
so he had maybe three or four B groups
and then a couple of fly groups and then
he had like an other group he had the
butterflies and you know moths group but
you didn't see that much of but he
didn't look at night so
well like like with aronia for example
we looked at a wild representative
aronia and then we looked at two compact
cultivars of aronia which really didn't
have a change in flower color and there
was no significant difference in the
insect visitation on a compact form in
fact with Clara we looked at ruby spice
we looked at a wild type and then we
looked at hummingbird and hummingbird
actually produces more flowers per
square in the area of plant and it had
more pollinators in some of the insect
categories but the ruby spice differed
in a couple of maybe one situation not
much difference there we looked at
Potentilla the wild Potentilla
goldfinger and pink beauty and we saw
differences there we saw differences
between the purple and the green and 9
bar and some differences with hydrangea
we looked at Annabelle which is largely
sterile florets yes nursery industry
tends to be fairly conservative so I'm
wondering what successes you've had in
introducing these native shrubs to the
nursery industry and what methods you
use to try to attract that you know good
question so how am i bringing these
plants to the growers so I did have a
grant that allowed me to propagate and
give them plants to trial and recruit
growers to an advisory group so I worked
with about 5 growers directly Prydz
corner farms Canterbury court planners
choice broke an hour which is more kind
of a specialty plant design build and
Summer Hill and so I gave them the
plants to trial and then I repeatedly
asked for feedback and I visited the
nursery and I think probably about 3 or
4 species have been added so they like
the prune is pew Muller they like I have
viburnum land - nowadays
no sorry at luncheon Arnie's that one I
don't know if they were I used the ice
gave that to a couple of specialty
nurseries
so the viburnum cast annuities are
newton cast annuities that one america
Gale they're growing they had been
growing calm tonyia and I'm holding a
grower workshop this winter for the new
propagation method I'm cutting so
hopefully hands-on
well dig side for shoots and let them
head propagator stick the cuttings and
then see where to plant and let's see
but they are like the big nurseries are
looking for selections of natives now so
prides and Monrovia and you know like
the Bailey and spring meadow they they
are looking for selections so if you
have unique germ plasm of a native I
think that's the way they want to go
with up with a cultivar selection
because the consumer wants a named plan
it's a small group of consumers that
want a wild type plant so so I think
about three or four species and that the
species may vary slightly so one of the
plants that I really like is round leaf
dogwood and it in its showing a lot of
promise with drought tolerance and just
one grower was just not interested in it
and then another one of the growers got
the prunus I don't know what he did with
it and then all of a sudden now he's got
people asking for people ask me and I
said well go try this grower who
actually when they asked me where can I
get it but didn't they give it to you
but then I said oh I think Canterbury
still has some and he went and got it
from there so it takes a while to catch
on certainly takes a while and then and
then they're like oh yeah we should be
growing that we're asking for that now
yeah I think they certainly will support
nectar foraging pollinators that's what
I've looked at we
looked at the underside of the leaves
for the larvae or the caterpillars and
that that certainly could be done you
could look at night foraging pollinators
as well which Jacobs not a night person
and I've concluded someone for that but
so we just wanted to look a little bit
just try to provide a little bit of
science to people as they make their
decisions and what's the best for their
landscape so I mean if you're doing
restoration
you know you not don't want to
necessarily put Ruby spice in not that
it didn't derive as a sport and may may
prepare you know be out there
III think they certainly can I think a
lot of non natives can as well but so I
think they can support natives quite
well insects right well thank you this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu